the cdc is defending the biden
administration's new guidelines for
reopening schools during the pandemic dr
rochelle wolenski told face the nation
that data suggests the vast majority of
covet transmission
takes place in the community not inside
school buildings
the white house has suggested only
schools in so-called blue
and yellow zones should be in fully
in-person mode
new data shared with cbs news shows that
just about one percent of students
currently
live in those zones more than 91 percent
live
in red zones those are communities with
significant transmission
where hybrid or remote learning is
recommended
we are joined now by michael ulsterholm
he's an epidemiologist and director of
the center for infectious disease
research and policy
at the university of minnesota and he
was a member of president biden's
transition covet 19 advisory board
he joins us to discuss let's start
michael with that 91 percent in the red
zones nobody wants that red color
do you think these cdc guidelines are
enough
i think they are enough particularly if
you're looking at children from k
to eight grade there we do see very
little transmission
between students or between students and
teachers when you get into the high
school age that's a bit of a different
issue
but there really is a real red flag
coming down the road i think
and that is these new variants that
we're talking about this particular one
from the united kingdom
i think is going to cause such a surge
in cases over the course of the next 14
weeks and i think a lot of schools are
going to be challenged to open at all
so if they don't have the resources
should they still stay open if they
don't have the resources to meet the
guidelines
how should that be handled well at this
point i think most schools can handle
the guidelines relative to the younger
kids
but the problem is is that again as i
pointed out as case numbers rise in our
communities which is what the cdc has
flagged
will be the problem so at this point
many areas can open up i don't think
they'll be open very long
because of what's coming down the pike
with cases i want to talk about the very
variant and variance in a second michael
but according to the cdc guidelines
vaccinating teachers
is not a prerequisite to reopening
do you think it should be well first of
all right now anthony we're in a race
with this variant
in terms of vaccination uh if we look at
the numbers right now there will be over
30 million americans over the age of 65
who will not have vaccine by the end of
march when we are going to be in very
very dark days
now we have to start making choices do
younger people
who are otherwise not at risk beyond
what it is in the community
for getting infected they're not at
increased risk for serious disease we
get in front of the line
of those who are if they do get infected
are likely to be seriously ill and die
so right now i think all the governors
all the mayors and even our federal
agencies are going to take a step back
and say
we just don't have enough vaccine to say
to everybody come on get in line
who are we going to start prioritizing
if i had to put my money right now
on saving the most lives keeping our
hospitals open
operating as best they can i would put
all my vaccine in 65 years older
so i know teachers may not want to hear
that but i think that's the right
message
i understand that michael so you're
talking about i mean if you're talking
about 14 weeks before this
reaches a peak is that what you're
saying you're saying this leads us right
into the beginning of the summer
into the next 14 weeks i think will be
the worst to the pandemic
people don't want to hear that but if we
look at what these variants
are doing particularly this one from the
united kingdom and see what it did in
europe see what it's done in the middle
east
it's now beginning to start that here in
the united states we are going to see
that unfold so
overall with schools they have to fit
into that and i think what we're going
to see is
big efforts to open the schools we will
get some
open beyond what we have now but then
it's going to likely be a real challenge
for them
in the next six to eight weeks as these
surge numbers begin to increase
and this will last for at least likely
up to 14 weeks
there are recent cases michael of people
testing positive
for covet even after they've been
vaccinated
how does that happen well first of all
these vaccines are really really good
gail they're very good
but they're not a hundred percent
necessarily and so even if a vaccine is
98
effective it means that two percent of
the people could still get infected
after being vaccinated
so this should isn't a surprise and it
still reinforces though however
how good these vaccines are because
these cases that we're talking about
of infection after two doses of vaccine
or even that matter one dose
actually are very very rare so are there
different guidelines if you've had one
vaccine and different guidelines if
you've had two vaccines
because people are still arguing about
whether we should be wearing masks
can you tell the difference between the
one and the two and the mass please
yeah well first of all one-dose vaccines
are something we have to look at very
seriously
or as i just pointed out a lot of
americans are not going to be
protected at all as we go into this next
big surge with the variant
two doses are ideal i wish everyone in
this country right now had two doses of
vaccine but that's not going to happen
until mid or late summer
that vaccine availability in the
meantime mass are the best thing we have
in terms of reducing transmission of
course in addition to that of just
distancing yourself don't put yourself
in harm's way
many people can't do that you yourselves
you have to go to work every day
you don't have that choice of protecting
yourself so that's where mass can play a
key role
michael osterholm thank you so much for
being with us this morning we appreciate
it